I was on a plane to Russia and the  engine exploded  I was looking out the window and the  entire engine just turned into a  fireball it was right after Sully had  that incident happen to him where the  geese flew into both ends and he landed  on the river this happened in one of the  engines and I was the was I was the only  person there that seemed to see this but  it was a flaming Fireball and it was all  Russian passengers and I kind of felt  like I'd already died and gone to heaven  because no one said anything  I was screaming at the top of my lungs  saying what the hell going on here and  these people just kind of look back to  me and the stewardess came out and said  we seem to have a slight problem here  Russian guy finally said what is the  problem  and said well we we lost one of our  engines  and he's he goes how many engines did we  have  well we had to now we have one